IVAN RAMIREZ: Hey, Fei.
How's it going?
FEI XUE: Hi, Ivan.
IVAN RAMIREZ: Wow.
These micro-kitchens
sure are getting bigger.
FEI XUE: I know,
so much chocolate.
IVAN RAMIREZ: Anyway,
machine learning
has been all the craze lately.
And we're looking for better
and faster ways to leverage it.
But we often run into
operation overhead,
especially considering
all the time and effort
it takes to develop
a specific model
and having it run
in different places.
FEI XUE: Yeah.
I actually hear
this issue a lot.
A common scenario is
that a data scientist
would develop his or
her model on a laptop,
train that model in the cloud,
then serve it in production,
maybe on prem or in
a different cloud.
In these different environments,
software and hardware
configurations could
totally be different.
That makes things break
easily when moving from one
environment to the other.
So what if I told you
that there would be a way
to easily develop, train,
and deploy machine learning
models in a very scalable and
flexible way by leveraging
Kubernetes?
IVAN RAMIREZ: Wow,
that would be amazing.
Do you think you could show us
all of that in five minutes?
FEI XUE: For sure.
I'll be using an open source
framework to do just that.
It is called Kubeflow.
It helps you run machine
learning models on Kubernetes.
Well, I will show you how to
use Kubeflow to first train
a TensorFlow model to recognize
handwritten numbers then
to serve that model on
an application server.
On top of that, we will
deploy a web interface
to interact with the model
over public internet.
So Kubeflow actually supports
distributive training,
as well as training on GPUs.
But to keep things
simple today, I
will demo CPU-only
training on a single node.
Let's jump into it.
IVAN RAMIREZ: Let's do it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FEI XUE: I have already spun
up a Kubernetes cluster.
Kubeflow uses a tool
called ksonnet to help
manage Kubernetes
development packages.
To get started, first I
deploy Kubeflow component
to my Kubernetes cluster.
Some of these components
include a Jupiter hub
for model development and TF
Job for managing training jobs.
After those are deployed,
I can run Kube Control
Get All and see a list of
all the resources provisioned
by Kubeflow.
Now that Kubeflow
is ready to go,
let's start training
in the model.
It's actually really easy.
I have already built a container
with existing Python code
and pushed it to the
Container Registry.
This Python code
trains the model
to recognize handwritten
digits then export
the model to a storage bucket.
Now I will deploy the
training component.
I set the parameters
for the training drop
to tell it where to find the
container in the registry.
You can now see in
the Workflow page,
I have a container being created
to perform the training job.
When it is done, the model
will be exported to a bucket.
It is going to take a little
while spinning up the container
and doing the actual training.
While this is happening,
let's set up a server
to serve the model.
I'm using a TF Serving
deployment to do it.
I will point the
server to the bucket
where our model
will be exported to.
Now, in the Workload
page, you can
see that I have a serving
deployment called Minstserv.
After that, let's
also deploy a web app
UI to interact with the model.
Here I have a simple
Flask app that
will connect with
the server that we
deployed in the last step.
Again, I have packaged
it into a container
and pushed it into the registry.
I use ksonnet to deploy
it with an external IP.
Back to the Workflow
page, you can see the web
UI deployment is also running.
Now let's check on the
status of our training job.
It is still running.
Let's look at the logs.
OK, it is almost done,
almost 90% there.
Now we can click on the
Refresh button here.
You can see the
training is now over,
and the model has been
uploaded to the bucket.
With that, we can
play with our model.
Let's go to our
web app component,
find the external IP,
connect to the server.
Here it is.
We can then use that server
to test on some random images.
So the first one, we're seeing
a picture of a handwritten zero,
and it's giving the correct
predictions of zero.
With that, let's test on
couple of other random images.
We can see that it's
giving the correct result.
So everything we just saw today,
from training, to surveying,
to web app UI, is all
happening on GKE Kubernetes
with Kubeflow.
IVAN RAMIREZ: Well,
Fei, that was amazing.
FEI XUE: Well, thanks.
Well, now you can easily
develop, train, and deploy
your machine learning models
everywhere on Kubernetes,
thanks to Kubeflow.
I want to give a big shout
out to Dan [? Senche, ?]
who developed the demo material.
Please like, comment,
and subscribe down below.
IVAN RAMIREZ: And if your
company's working on any cool
projects and you'd like
to reach out to the team,
go ahead and click on the
link down below as well.
[MUSIC PLAYING]